ah
oh
[Music]
ah yes
yes
[Music]
in the youtube chat more like a dark
broom oof
oof i'll give your mother a bit of my
bloody stick
[Music]
hello
[Music]
um
hi dev high five yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
oh right right then
okie dokie folks it would appear
it would appear friends here we go
okay currently going out live live via
games
via game sports twitch live via youtube
hello friends let's get this one going
it is
a stream called the dark room raising
money there for ablegamers
as part of part of play for all
and now for all of these lovely things
that i've just said
here is a video that will explain
nothing
we are about to play a game a game that
is super easy
like your mom a game like the text-based
adventure games from the 1980s
and if you've ever played a text-based
adventure game
you know there are two words that
shouldn't appear in that sentence
and they are adventure and game
the rules are simple rule one find the
light switch
rule two find your family rule three
escape the dark room
if you succeed you will be reunited with
your loving attractive
unmutilated brethren and win this
beautiful flamboyant potato but if you
fail
[Laughter]
you're dying
[Music]
you are now inside the world's only
live-action video game
the dark room activating graphics
[Music]
ah now then
hello hello one and all hello
now it is a bloody joy to be with you
each and every one of you it doesn't
matter where you
are if you're on a god damn service
that's actually for gamers
like twitch or if you're on something
that's essentially for low-key porn
like youtube now some of you might have
thought that twitch is for low-key porn
but if you're going to be like that you
could [ __ ] off
now welcome welcome one and all it is a
joy
and this is a charity stream raising
money for able gamers
who are a disabled gamer advocacy group
and
who help make people who feel a sense of
social isolation
help get those people a little thing
called friends
now of course some of you might lead
might be deeply isolated of course you
are
you're the kind of people who at ten in
the morning are going to go and see
what's happening on the gamespot twitch
or youtube channel
however we are about to do a thing for a
very good cause
it is a joy to have each and every one
of you here
now in a moment some of you will die and
in a while we might talk
to some of your friends from gamespot
like lucy james
and tam and some special guests but
right now
we are about to behave very badly for a
very good cause
and here is how the game works four
options
will appear on the screen around me if
you were called upon to play and that is
all of you
you pick the options just by writing the
color that's next to them
this one here is blue the color of my
feelings of sadness every time call of
duty announces another game
this one here is yellow the color of
urine
this one here is green the sweet and
enjoyable color of grass
and this one here is red the color of
what happens the second i go
outside look at me for god's sake i look
like the ghost of a ghost
there are children on my street who
genuinely think i'm draco malfoy's dad
hello to going off topic down there in
the chat hello to black viper 94
as well now then if
you are ready to play and if you're in
the game spot discord
you can pick an option just by you'll
notice that all of the options suddenly
appear
you click on the color of the option
that you want that's how it works
dave doggo says i thought you were an
australian tarzan i
certainly am but that's mostly the noise
i make when i see electricity we don't
have much of that in australia
we've got some but we don't have any
functional internet so then
let us do this i will count to three i
will say the words you awake to find
yourself
in a dark room and what i would like
is it doesn't matter what chat you're in
feel free to write down
you are weak to find yourself in a dark
room
perfect then pick the option you want by
writing the color in the chat or
clicking it in the discord that's
how it goes and remember at all times
there's the donation link
down there let's get able gamers some
money
as part of play for all and now
let us begin one two
three you were weak to
find yourself in a dark room
show me show me in the chat in the chat
that you are alive you are
gamers aren't you very good over there
in the gamespot twitch chat
that's right paul craig darrens of the
world's unite
over there in the youtube now show me
show me
show me show me good you awake to find
yourself
in a dark room and now pick an option
what will you do what will you do look
at you
doing a gaming yes indeed i want you to
understand that this game is essentially
subnautica
minus the water and the craft and the
ortica and the subbing
now then thank you steve well done
stephen faulkner there correct you'll
wait to find yourself in a dark room
write your colors down and get your vote
hello lucy james
yes we are here hello god damn it's
gamer time get it going
and wrestling guys are gamers hot
diggity damn
yes that's right you know what when the
stereotype is that you live in your
mother's basement
and a global pandemic means everyone
suddenly does don't you feel good about
yourselves
i'm gonna give you five more seconds on
this screen
five four three two
one you have selected blue why why
because it's dark darren's and a room
darrens and you're awake in it darrens
now then what now what now
friends will you sleep it's been such a
big day
will you turn on the light switch do you
even have the ability to do so
will you look at the rumor will you open
map and remember
you can vote if you're in the game stop
discord
yes game spot game spot damn it damn it
damn it got it wrong can't believe it
yes
game spot the website does the game
reviews not not game stop the people who
charge you for the second hand games
come up pick an option friends
pick an option what will it be and
remember folks donate thank you
thank you tamal now remember folks
donate to ablegamers everyone will get a
shout out
if you donate everyone will get a shout
out everyone get deeply thanked
you are raising money for disabled
gamers and what a wonderful thing that
is to do
this is the world's most popular hobby
and you are making it so that people can
get involved
in it now come on then you have selected
oh it would appear to be sleep
really really
worn out worn out from and look i am
about to swear for the fifth time on a
charity stream but
worn out from doing [ __ ] all
you sleep and when sleep has ended
you were weak to find yourself in a dark
room
i thought hello tamor hi hot rob
hello sweethearts now i thought this was
going to be the elite gamers
gathered together and so it is you've
clicked one thing then you've fallen
asleep
my word it's like it's amazon prime day
and it is amazon prime day which of
course is like christmas except the
elves have to do all of their poos and
weeds in their vans
now then pick an option pick an option
you've all just heard the sound of
something in the background in the
background fall over
great that's okay celebrigo i don't we
need you to be in the darkroom with me
i'm not in the darkroom
we are raising money for charity mate
also there we go
not always fun to get a plug for
yourself in our charity stream but i'm
going to
so then pick an option friends
pick an option what will it be what will
it be folks what will it be
a section of the background just had a
nervous breakdown
now friends come on gamers
this is like a text adventure from the
80s
what will it be folks what will it be
that you've
i cannot write ah now then you know what
it's like when you've got a background
that the people can't even see and then
that falls down
now that what is this garbino hey let me
tell you something essay
it's very beautiful and it's raising
money for charity and when i say charity
i don't just mean
your face when girls look at it and
think okay i'll sit on it just so it
shuts up
you have selected yes that was a special
shout out over there
for um what's your name sato kyber right
then
you have again selected why why
because it's dark darren's and a room
darren's and you're awake in it darrens
now pick an option pick an option
now then i am a cutie pie thank you
remixed mommy you're lovely
remixed mommy in the youtube chat you
could stay you
are now my favorite thank you you're my
favorite of anyone who is here
now then and i like all of you because
remember folks this is a charity stream
and i am behaving very very badly very
badly
for a goddamn good cause so come along
folks
come along and donate some money at that
tildefy link for play for all
yes for ablegamers wonderful friends
wonderful and chloe raccoon has put in
twenty dollars thank you
guberpotamus has put in twenty thank you
arya has put in twenty thank you
matt hawk puts in 10 and says the room
is so dark yes and david noor has put in
20 bucks as well
marvelous let us continue we've only
just begin
begun mikey says dude what show did you
used to be on was it bravo tv or
something
i was on a show called video game nation
it was on challenge tv hi def high five
you're the only person who ever watched
it and that's why it was cancelled
and that's why i'm here now you have
selected turn on light switch
really that's always been your problem
yes that's where i met lucy
the difference between her and eyes i
know as i'm unemployed and that's why i
was available to do this
you have selected turn on light switch
fine
fine then that's always been your
problem
gamers self-esteem too high think you
can turn on anything
even inanimate objects what would you
turn the light switch on
with well what would you turn the light
switch on with
and speaking of speaking of ah now
that's fantastic wrestling god's stream
says
i'm disabled myself this is a really
good cause unfortunately i can't donate
i'm too young well good on you
good on you for agreeing this is a
really good cause and good on you for
also being very honest there with why
you couldn't donate if anyone's sitting
there at the moment going
oh but my wallets you know it's so far
away it's
it's on the other side of the room and
you're able to go get it go get it
now then yes pick an option
think of this as deliveroo but what you
bring is a life-changing experience for
someone else
you're selected with my finger really
you would turn the light switch on with
your finger really
this is you oh
i'm in a dark room
well i know what to do now
yes you would turn the light switch on
with your finger
if your finger could find the light
switch and your finger would be able to
do that
if your finger could see in the dark
can it
[Laughter]
you know what's wonderful i've asked you
the question can it
and at that exact moment my controller
has decided to there it is
fine fine the problem lasted such a
small amount of time i didn't need to
draw attention to it
didn't need to draw attention to it but
i did there we are
have any of you people ever been heckled
by your own show
it just happened to me hello jacob
this is a live action video game raising
money for ablegamers
pick an option by writing down the color
that's next to it everyone's currently
trapped in a dark room
also lucy james lucy james we might uh
we might have a little chat with you
lucy in a little while if that'd be good
yes might get you in the discord have a
little communication with our faces
now then select friends select tell me
about the nature of your fingers can
your fingers
see in the dark can it
yes tag me and i will yes friends
but the gamers are doing so well you
have selected
oh my finger how do you access the
options write down the color mate
write down the color in the chat that's
all that you have to do oh dog
write down the color yes yash partha i
once again asking for you enough
i am once again asking for your
financial support but in this case it's
for some disabled gamers
and also wrestling godstream is going
shopping with their friends next
wednesday what an amazing story you
didn't have to tell everyone that but
that must be fun
you have selected your finger can see no
it can't
it's a finger however you're darren's
yes your fingers can do some amazing
things no one else's can
why is that darren's tell me
tell me why your fingers across that you
make it out alive that's very good don't
pick your nose that way you'll rip your
nose off
right then select yes you'll do terrible
damage to your nostrils
now select friends select
hello somerset nice to see you again
select an option by writing down a color
that's right i am well done
i like someone whose username is an
existential crisis
you you're selected i'm living the dream
fine then and what dream are you living
i will just point out to the assembled
gamers there is exactly
one option one option don't try to make
emergent gameplay happen
don't try to make emergent gameplay
happen with your goddamn rocket jumping
and things
also tamar i do apologize shows or
show's been on 17 minutes we're already
running slightly late
no well now go on you have selected
the dream of being radioactive yes
yes you are radioactive you were born in
chernobyl
but look oh oh how positive
how positive you are how positive one of
you has selected the option black
excellent you won't go back now then
that's right you're pretty sure you've
got super powers
oh you reckon you record you've got
super powers
like what
friends it would appear
it would appear that you have turned to
ask me is internal bleeding a superpower
it most certainly is not it most
certainly is not
i have no choice but to inform you
friends you
are radioactive and slowly you begin to
die
and when i say slowly i mean oh right
[ __ ] now
[Applause]
boom okey dokey now hello
hello everyone hello folks hello folks
hello folks hello folks hello folks
hello folks g'day
g'day everybody my name is john
robertson how are you
yes the streamers robotron here on
twitch and uh
just wanted to say to you a really fast
g'day
now just going to take a little moment
what we just did there
that is what we're doing for the next
two hours
raising money as i've said for
ablegamers as part
of gamespot's play for all now what i
would like to do at the moment
is i'm going to say hello to a very nice
person who is a
nice enough to invite me to come and be
here so lucy james folks you might know
if you've been following
a gamespot for a while you might love
lucy james
let's say hello right about you know
what
do you reckon folks just out of interest
in the chat should i oh yeah for the
various bill hi def
high five hello hello youtube people
hello hello israel garcia g'day mate how
are you
hello people over there in the twitch
hello one and all now then
real fast do you reckon i should warn
lucy that i'm about to ring her on the
discord you reckon
should i should i give this one a go or
should i just
click her name and see what happens
friends what do you think
just out of interest friends
yes i think we can absolutely all agree
why don't we just ring her immediately
there we are no need for any warning
whatsoever
hello hello how are you i'm doing well
thanks how are you
i'm very well now now my good friend
lucy at the moment you are not visible
to the people uh here however i will
sort that out momentarily here we go
um oh no well well what's up
i turned my camera on i've ruined
everything no no you you've ruined
nothing
what i just discovered is that the
window where you're meant to be
is still my camera so um at the moment
if if you do want to talk uh i can make
you a puppet
if you like it yes absolutely
that's very good work lucy and uh isn't
the show going well so far
it is thank you so much for doing this
this is so much fun
okay let's get your actual face
there you are folks okay sorry i've just
inadvertently docked like 90 percent of
our friends
okay here we go dude i love the way when
i said 90 of our friends i think
mentally you went john we have one
mutual friend
so well no we have like
all of jinx we've got um neil and ange
are very good friends we have a lot of
friends in common indeed now here we go
folks
uh now lucy you are you are indeed
visible hello
friend hello hello hello would you
bearing in mind
at the moment are for all of the good
people out there wherever you are on the
planet and bearing in mind
if you are currently thank you very much
whatever that was uh if you are
currently watching this in america i
appreciate that
in in terms of pacific time this is a
bit full on for this hour of the morning
hope you're having a good one um yeah
sorry anyone over there
oh dear when i did that anyone in l.a
will have presumed that was a literal
earthquake um
but yeah lucy
do you want to tell the people what it
is we're doing today why we're here
a little bit little bit of the on
message good times
oh the unmessaged good times are my
favorite good times uh so no
uh every every year for the past couple
years we have done a charity event to
raise money for different causes
and this year it is our 25th anniversary
gamespot is 25 which
online years are like dog years so that
makes us like 150 or something
um and we wanted to give back to the
gaming community
and in particular we love the work that
ablegamers does and
uh like you mentioned earlier they're a
fantastic charity
that work to like with the uh like with
disabled gamers
in so many different ways they help
uh make and give specialized hardware so
like
some sometimes people's disabilities
can't use like
like i have an xbox controller here and
they can't use it and so they work
with engineers to create specialized
controllers and give those to people
because obviously that is very expensive
they also work to combat social
isolation by putting on events and
getting people mixing and talking to
each other
and as well as that they're
accessibility consultants so that uh
you know more accessibility options are
put in games
and one of the big reasons why like i've
been following this stuff for a while
and obviously we're friends with steve
um who is on one of the streams tomorrow
but i think after the last year
i know that i have been very isolated
socially and i i actually genuinely
realized that
the most that i would talk to my friends
would be while we're playing games
and what a kind of incredible mission
that ablegamers has where it's like they
want more people to game
more people to have those experiences
and to
make those friendships and relationships
and so
it was a no-brainer really when we were
deciding and so we put on this week of
streams
so yesterday we had like jake valdino
h bomber guy uh super eyepatch wolf
today we've got you and kind of funny
we've got folks uh we've got steve c
swann himself from ablegamers we have
um pro zd pro zd i'm in the i'm in the
uk now i don't have to say zd
uh pro zd uh we've got like resident
evil
with i think i can say it now but we
actually have lady d
coming on uh with mike mary we've got
a giant bomb and yeah i was gonna say
like
step on everyone for uh for a donation
um and also yeah and we've got folks
from like roosty teeth
and fun house and kind of funny and so
it's also just a great way of like
getting
friends that like people that we love
in real life and like admire online from
afar respectfully
uh on to do some cool stuff and
hopefully raise a lot of money and thank
you to everyone who has been donating
um it's been so nice and so and thank
you to you
it is it is bloody flowing in at the
minute um
i gotta say a big uh everyone's names
get kind of cut off on the tiltify for
me
so um thank you capaci good on you
uh with 30 quid fireworm with 10
caliber you 13.50 great game great cause
dad's son who put in 200 and says any
bacon chippy's left dead that's actually
for me good on you
good on you mate that's that's great
please don't come looking for child
support you know i've got no cash
uh and robcat with a hundred dollars
let's go
love you all bloody whoa
and um yeah i mean the points well made
about social isolation we've just had 18
months where everyone on the planet has
understood what social isolation is
even more than they probably did already
because everyone feels a bit isolated at
some point or another
however if you're disabled that happens
oh most of the bloody time you know
it becomes a moment of going oh well i'd
like to go over there
but um there i can't physically get
there
you know yeah there's some so much more
considerations and like i think
like we take a lot of things for granted
and um
yeah when we were kind of looking up all
the ablegamers um
like they have all these incredible
videos and like learning resources and
it's just something that you
you don't think about because it doesn't
happen to you and so
we want to be there to like help this
cause because it is it's so
worthy and it's you know and like their
mission is so everyone can game and that
is such
and there are so many different ways
that they do it it's fantastic so we
want to help something that everyone
who's watching can understand everyone
who's watching can
get get absolutely behind this is an
advocacy group they're the people who go
out and do some education
for the per you know they're the people
who educate you letting you know
actually people do feel left out
and they're the people who give those
people the abilities to not feel left
out so bloody superb
lucy for the people at home
people at home some of whom deeply
confused there's a bloke called mass
gamers
uh who seems to want someone's attention
uh hello
i presume that was a cry for help it
looked like what um what we're going to
do
what we're going to do is uh would you
like to play a round of the dark room
so that the people who are in the chat
who are no doubt going to do
very well very well eventually can maybe
learn something from you what do you
reckon
yes please all right then well in that
case now folks
please understand that gamespot as you
know
a deeply professional organization
you've got you've got little things like
resources and you've got things like
competence to you
right all this stuff watch as i now
mystifyingly transform into
the dark room
[Music]
and i've just realized this would be a
lot easier if i had
my phone ah
right then right now then
lucy james you will play
are you ready i'm ready fine
now i have said your name but i will ask
what is it
what is your name i don't remember but i
feel like it starts with a d
maybe a start with a d
you'll be referred to henceforth as game
reviewer darren
there we are that'll work oh hang on do
you do you guys use percentages on
gamespot
no we do um we do one through ten no
half points
no decimals seven out of ten darren it's
still good but the fans are angry
seven out of ten darren let's do this
so folks i am going to count to three
i'm going to say the words you will wait
to find yourself in a dark room
whatever you're watching and feel free
to spam the chat with that phrase
and lucy will attempt to escape a live
action text adventure
let's go seven out of ten down one two
three
you are awake to find yourself in a dark
room
your options are why sleep find light
switch or go north
why why because it's dark seven out of
ten down
and a room seven out of ten down and
you'll awaken it seven out of ten darum
your options of sleep turn on light
switch or acknowledge you understand
i acknowledge that i understand i'm glad
i'm glad that you understand and yet
also
you stand under you have glitched the
game
just like that character from fallout 3
who they couldn't make a train so they
just put a goddamn train on a bloke's
head
and he just walked around you have
glitched through the floor
i have no choice but to inform you
[Applause]
well that was fun there we go that was
that one that was great
so so folks that this is what we're
doing
lucy thank you for playing thank you for
having me
do you have any other messages for the
nice folks out there before i
turn on them again uh no thank you all
uh for watching playing and donating
tinyurl.com
playful2021 if you have some dollars to
spare
every donation is appreciated and if you
can't donate please share the stream
because
you might reach someone who can very
very nice also thank you very much to mr
hyde the first
popping in 25 quid 25. folks
that is the fabulous uh lucy james lucy
james games right there
and all right thank you new friend also
um
lovely taymor hussein was meant to be on
15 minutes ago and i hope isn't becoming
annoyed
that he hasn't been brought on i'm sure
he's fine
are you are you sure sure he's fine
in two hours then all right then see you
bye well that was lucy james folks that
was the marvelous lucy jones round of
applause folks
round of applause please for lucy james
if you would be so good
doesn't matter where you are and yeah if
you want to write down clap
but you're all good no rush you beauty
thanks taymor
rydo so folks
the time has come the time has come for
all of you to play again
bearing in mind friends the game
reviewer
the game reviewer glitched through the
floor now that would normally be a sign
that the game is badly made
but i will have you know that this game
is made like a aaa game
which is to say it's badly made now and
you've paid
full price now but in five years
it'll be mediocre i'm looking at you
destiny
right then here is how
we play once again
we are about to play a game a game that
is super
easy like your mom
a game like the text-based adventure
games from the 1980s
and if you've ever played a text-based
adventure game
you know there are two words that
shouldn't affect in that sentence
and they are adventure and game
the rules are simple rule one find the
light switch
rule two find your family rule three
escape the dark room
if you'll succeed you will be reunited
with your loving attractive
unmutilated brethren and win this
beautiful
flamboyant potato
[Music]
you are once again back inside the
world's only live-action video game
activating graphics
[Laughter]
so let us make some things happen
i will count to three i will say the
words you awake
to find yourself in a dark room some of
you will wonder why the graphics for
this game looks so much like the bad guy
from ghostbusters 2.
right then when i say you awake to find
yourself in a dark room
spam the chat wherever you are then pick
an option by writing down the color
that's next to it
here blue
dye yellow wabadi wabadai
green the color of gangrene and red
the color of stalin let's go
one two three
you were weak to find yourself in a
dark room ah
go go go go go go go go go go go
yes ah
and it turns out as well that wonderful
gesture my radars has arrived
tamor you've been pushed back you've
been pushed back again mate
this is the show that taymor nearly
appeared in
now friends write down an option write
down a color
that's right thank you and hakido
i like to dote on anarchists because
they're physically weak you see
well not always weak but you've got to
hand it to them they've strengthened
their convictions mostly for vandalism
now then come on and don't forget to
donate
don't forget to donate folks to
ablegamers don't forget
to donate they are making it so disabled
people feel less alone
and there can be almost no noble cause
than that
you have selected sleep really
you little shits i tell you that you can
raise money for disabled gamers
and you pick sleep fine
pricks you sleep and when
sleep has ended you awake to find
yourself
in a dark room
[Music]
i have two hearts down there and neither
of them love you yes
you know what you just did you know what
you just did
we're working so hard you know well
we're not but the people at ablegamers
are
now come on pick an option friends
once again blue up here yellow down here
green you don't want sweet green look
ground and down here
sleep oh you're not even going to sleep
a second time are you
do don't you dare don't you dare your
bastards
oh if i start seeing you write down red
i'll be tremendously annoyed
after actually that's not true your
parents have wanted you to sleep for
years
hello you keep walking around and
talking now then
you have selected check pockets fine
congratulations you're wearing blue
check pockets
it's a hideous fashion choice and you
wouldn't have known because the room's
so dark
but i decided to tell you um
thank you wrestling god streams i like
you as well now then
are you going to put your hands in your
pockets maybe one hand
are you going to find the exit you know
what
i've reset your little options i've
reset your democracy
[Laughter]
you will have choices the way i tell you
now then
select what will you do
what will you do
[Music]
much in the way of going north yes ah
also it's tamil i've been mispronouncing
a friend's name the entire time
i do apologize now then yeah
why why because it's the right thing to
do you pricks
that's right why also because it's dark
downs
and a room darrens and you're awaken it
downs and we're back here again
there are over 700 different screens
in this game 700 different screens
i have people playing on youtube i have
people playing on my twitch
i have people playing on game sports
twitch
and also i would like you to sing out
what games are you all playing
the games that you play when you do get
some free time what are you enjoying
because whatever game they are do you
find it yourself just looping back to
the main menu
over and over and over again rainbow six
tom clancy's rainbow six just join the
army
elite dangerous i like a sort of common
danger
hmm now then yes there is the dark room
video game still in production third
year of steam early access having a
great time
now then i like you too captain spalding
you have selected find light switch
how will you find the light switch
you're in a dark room
you need the light switch to see do you
see
radders prefers to play oregon trail yes
well you've got dysentery we all know
about you
now then hang on an rpg game called
tokyo mirage sessions
well of course it must be an rpg
only somebody playing an rpg feels the
need to clarify the genre
oh it's obscure you won't have heard of
it it's called final fantasy vii
now then you told me that in confidence
yes at the same time yes but
unfortunately
dysentery is a gift for everyone because
you see
it's like a normal bowel movement but it
tells a tale a hideous
brown tale now then you love playing ufc
four
yes i also like getting in my underpants
and causing trouble
now then pick your options pick your
options
our next guest is raddersgaming who is
tragically stricken with dysentery from
a trip to oregon
one of the best souvenirs that you can
pick up now what genre is playing with
myself oh it's an rpg but unfortunately
your experience points go down the
crevice of your back
oh it depends are you lying down when
you do it anyway now
then you have selected i don't see
we know you don't see that is why you
need to also do we all like the fact
that to censor myself from saying ass i
said crevice of your back
pretty good isn't it shame i said [ __ ]
like nine times
right then you have selected i don't see
we know you don't see that is why you
need to
pick an option for it i thought it was
terribly polite toby sponge i thought so
yes yes please stop [ __ ] swearing yes
indeed
who taught you this appalling bloody
language prick
now then select gang select you love
jack box as well yeah mate we all love
punching jack
i love a game of jack box it's good fun
he comes to you he's in a box you beat
the [ __ ] out of him put him back in the
box
send him home good fun then of course if
anyone asks you say you don't know jack
you selected find light switch really
how will you find the light switch
you're in a dark room you need the light
switch to see
do you see pick an option
i will give you five seconds five
four three two
one you have selected i see
[ __ ] you see you're in a dark room
[Laughter]
ah now then
friends to dysentery everywhere radders
will be up next
followed by our newly enjoyable very
patient chum
tamor you have selected touch wall
you caress the wall it's indifferent to
you
riley has forgotten every game they've
ever played i hate to tell you
but they've forgotten you as well it
doesn't matter how many times you save
the ai can never love you back now
friends
gen clone has put in ten dollars thank
you jan clone
friends we're not just here to hang [ __ ]
on triple a games
we're not just here to inconvenience of
bloku's journalism i respect
we're not just here to attack some
special guests
we're also here to raise money for
ablegamers keep
those donations flowing it's like the
spice in june
usually to touch other wall really
well now the first wall is jealous
i remember wrestlemania the arcade game
it made me feel as though i'd had the
amount of head injuries a normal
wrestler would have had
now then come on and is that a
compliment about its realism
or am i just saying that it was bad now
come on
[Music]
what will it be hello jean-luc now then
what will it be friends hmm
since you've decided that you want to be
tremendously good friends with the walls
yes
thank you paulie who's cheering in bits
that's cool if you could donate direct
that's great but
thank you very much you'll select a
touch yet another wall
this is all of you oh
i'm in a dark room
you've become some sort of weird war
bother haven't you darren's
now the walls have lost all respect for
you how did they have respect to lose
their walls
now then pick an option
oh that is remarkably accurate yes look
at you look at you you little brick
strokers
you've been playing spirit pharah
recently that's all right and pretty yes
it is
yes it is also goodness i
checking the old oh yes now then friends
it is a bloody joy seeing the money
going up for the charity
hansura hancher has put in 100
a round of applause please for hanshira
putting in a hundred dollars thank you
for the darwin's
that's a hundred bucks that's gone in
folks the show has been on
less than an hour and we've raised over
500 us dollars
you marvelous people and if you're
watching in australia
that's like oh my you can buy like 10 of
the country
10 of the whole country will then bloody
incredible now then
you've selected smell room the dark room
[Music]
of roomy darkness and also charitable
donations
also riley gibson in the youtube have
these walls never heard of healthy
polyamory
i have a feeling they probably haven't
they are after all
walls i mean it is possible to healthy
polyamory
however once again walls
they are literally barriers even if
they were able to hear of it they
probably wouldn't like it their job is
to keep things out and in
pick an option pick an option and if you
die
we shall go and bring in our special
guest radders
yes now then
pick an option friends pick an option
are we saying that doesn't make sense
are we saying we're gonna
there's no way you're going to enter the
cheat code
absolutely not unbelievable believable
really hello bluex nice to see you
i expected more from you people this
is gamespot not bloody game faq
find them enter cheat code
all right i thought games would just pay
to win these days
all right fine what cheat code will it
be
what cheat code will you enter they're
both classics
one actually they're both from a time
where people wore parachute pants
just in one of them people used to also
run around with scimitars there's a
little bird
jafar i don't know now then
thank you rousey rowley there cheering
out for hampshire there
now quickly quickly now when we say pay
to win
this game is not pay to win although
when you donate you help people win
and you help yourself win it's actually
just very good for the soul and remember
you are soul now then you have selected
abba abba fine you have selected
the level skip the level skip cheat
from disney's aladdin on the mega drive
which is also known as the genesis in
america
because the bible's quite popular there
right then
fine you have selected the level skip
the level skip congratulations
you awake to find yourself in a dark
room
but now you're skipping
yay yay
yay how whimsical oh you're playing soul
calibur are you
wonderful you have a very low caliber of
soul friend
but yes go on
now then ah
go ah skip
skip skip skip skip skip
yes you're having the most wonderful
whimsical marvelous time
if only you could have a picnic oh such
fun you skip you skip in the direction
you believe to be north
and you skip right in
to mr spike the 10 inch meat spike who
lives in the wall
he impales you through your chest you
die
like a fluffish vampire the difference
is that
no sort of teeny bopper goth's going to
cry for you
you may wish to apply your eyeliner and
weep though because i have no choice but
to inform you you die you die
you die you die
you die you die
okay all right then hello hello once
again folks
hello g'day john here
ah my my my my clean up aisle four thank
you very much okay
we've played another group round once
again you have all died
however you have also thus far right
what whoa whoa
ho ho ho ho i want to say a big thank
you
a big thank you to everyone who's
donating so far it is absolutely bloody
marvelous
uh thank you to fictional states who put
in five us dollars
fps for fps poorly wonderful sorry yes
i'm sorry i always
fps poorly so good on you uh with 20
bucks
tom smith putting in 10 and mr psychic
mr psychic who's put in 101 dollars
with the phrase take that handshare so
folks
people aren't just donating to
ablegamers today people aren't just
donating
so that disabled gamers are able to play
video games people aren't just donating
so that equipment is made for them so
they're able to
and so that disability advocacy groups
are able to bring them in
and make them feel included people are
also donating
to spite their friends and that's
perfect
folks evil done in the service of good
is
good or more to the point whatever you
do to pop some money in the kitty here
is good those of you who thought
themselves will pop some money in the
kitty
and are now looking at a one dollar note
and the nearest visible kitten
please keep your thoughts and hands to
yourself now friends
we're going to right now we're going to
right now we're going to get a hold of
wonderful writers who have volunteered
their time this is a fabulous streamer
going to come in and say hello right now
please welcome again
uh so folks with a round of applause
wherever you are wherever you're
watching
and um there's going to be much in the
way of incompetence as i once again
failed to uh do the discord call
correctly
uh here we go so much in the way of and
i call you
and here we go right
maybe hello hello
we got you hello hello my love how are
you doing
i'm doing good thank you how are you i
am um i look
i i shan't lie to you i am an
increasingly sweaty man
uh who no one needs to know is wearing
shorts i don't normally wear shorts i'm
a goth it's not a thing
you know i am i am milk from below the
knees i am the ghost of a ghost down
there
but um so help me god that the only
reason the room's bright at the moment
is i've just put you know the shorts are
visible
no lights are on in here so yeah
the the the light is just reflecting off
your shins oh 100
although some of the younger people in
the channel go oh or you're foreign but
that's okay
now my darling my darling how are you
doing hello
i'm i'm doing all right thank you i'm uh
starting to finally recover from the
second jab of the vaccine
so i'm feeling good folks if you would
be so good a round of applause please
for second jabs a round of applause for
second jabs right there
that's wonderful i'd invite you to clap
your hands ratters but you don't need to
your arms will hurt for a little while
well done well done also thank you very
much lo martia
raiding in lo marty is going to be
joining us on the stream later on
what a joy now radders my darling
yes last time i saw you we were doing a
charity stream
of of let's be fair similar degrees of
dysfunction
and i think it was slightly more
delirious oh well i can always we can
always make that happen
more hang on here we go look
children look it's it's [ __ ] and sweet
oh how tremendous
there we are goodness that's that's a
childhood flashback i never wanted
well yep
all right so there we are now yes please
don't act like something strange has
happened nothing's going on
now writers my love would you like to
play a round of the dark room
i e i would excellent and before we do
that
why don't you tell the nice people what
it is you do
tell the people what it is you do friend
i um i play video games
um no i'm i'm rudders i'm a disabled
streamer
on twitch um hopefully one day
branching out to youtube and or a
stable job um and
i stream four days a week over on my
channel twitch.tv
gaming and you can watch me break every
single game
i ever play really break
every single game you ever play
i'm not joking when i played um
escape from monkey island for the first
time i
glitched the game in the way that no one
had ever seen really
yes well you fight like a dairy farmer
[Laughter]
and i don't remember the comeback and
that is how you break that bit you just
break it by not doing it that's
brilliant
you found a way to kill the funniest
game ever made
well done you're welcome
let's get tim schaefer on the phone
right then
my love my love let's see if you can
break monkey island i'm very
oh thank you wenlock who just said how
appropriate you fight like a cow
that's very nice although given that
there was a bit of a gap there
it now just seems as though they're
being mean to me [ __ ] you
you people i will milk you no i won't
you oh oh damn it okay that's even worse
now they're just gonna milk you so this
is not helping
i've been very lonely for some time so
that's very pleasant
now then um well thankfully we're going
into a dark room you'll get some privacy
well sure if any if any german viewers
are watching there are a couple
couple of quite strong men going i've
been in a lot of dark rooms that weren't
even
private right then here we go
here we go so ratters please come with
me on a journey
to the dark room you've managed to break
every game you've ever played
the game will take out as a challenge
here we go then
and a three and a two and a absolutely
bloody seamless
oh good acting impending
oh rogers
rather's gaming the monkey breaker
you awake to find yourself in a dark
oh my god the controller broke
no she's actually possessed of a power
she's actually possessed of a power oh
my god no
no yes yes ah
the fourth my powers no my powers
why would you do this to a charity
stream
i guess people will have to just donate
to fix it
yes that's a good point
i feel hello children
i feel as though only money can
bring tinkerbell back to life
bloody do it you people right it's
working let's go
radio game breaker down
you awake to find yourself in a dark
room
your options are wise sleep fine lights
which will go north pick one
uh why why
oh hold up all right why because it's
dark down
and a room down and you're awake in it
darren
your options asleep turn on light switch
or acknowledge you
understand um
i'm going to sleep
worn out worn out from light
conversation why not
after all we are a twitch streamer and
isn't that just essentially an introvert
that occasionally wants people to look
in the window
you sleep and when sleep has ended
you awake to find yourself in a dark
room
yes back once again at old popular wise
sleep fine lights which will go north
pick one
i would like to go and find the light
switch how will you find the light
switch
you're in a dark room you need the light
switch to see
do you see your options are i see i
don't see
check pockets or check pockets
so check pockets and check pockets uh
very different options very different
correct
okay um i would like to
check pockets which one
i just said that check pockets sure yep
no no very good very good let's not
forget that i'm just an
australian doing a voice european
intricacies mean
nothing to me i can't understand how to
catch a bus in this town
anyway red please
thank you also what a
wonderful cow noise i thought you were
doing before i realized you were just
rolling your ass
right there you are selected
red czech pockets congratulations
your pockets were made in the czech
republic it doesn't help you escape but
it's
lovely to know there is one option it
reads will you ever be kind to me
i'm already gonna i'm gonna will you
ever be kind to me
oh well now
how the worm has turned and the shoes on
the other foot and the worms wearing it
and i don't like it mother
have it killed right
i will if the shoe is on the other foot
does that mean my feet are banana feet
yes certainly that's exactly what that
means of course thank you
yep no worries and you know what they
say about people with banana feet
they've got banana feet and they
shouldn't be shamed
now then here we go their feet are high
in potassium
right then now you want an energy boost
suck that toe that's what i say
anyway folks that's enough of whatever
this is becoming so then
people in the chat people in the chat
this is what i want right now
the question has been asked will i ever
be kind
to our friend raddus our friend rattus
who has come here
to help us raise money for ablegamers i
put it to you
i put it to you they are a game breaker
they have destroyed my controller we
ended up in a very strange comedy
cul-de-sac about bananas for no
particular reason
in which i looked weird er than normal
so should i be kind
should i be kind to side decide friends
decide
the word coming in on gamespot is be
kind to this sweet bean
the word coming in on my chat is hello
i'm the foot guy
well it's me now isn't it yes the word
coming in
on youtube is kinda wrong
excellent oh now then it would appear
now it's coming in be kind be kind be
kind fine
despite the fact it will not only
inconvenience our next guest lomardia
who is coming in allegedly in one minute
and tamor
who is meant to be on 45 minutes ago but
is still
still waiting and getting pushed back i
will be kind to you
you do not die everyone in the chat
all together you awake to
find yourself in a dark room
your options are wise sleep fine lights
which will go north go
find light switch how will you find the
light switch you're in a dark room
you need the light switch to see do you
see
the options are i see i don't see check
pockets and the very popular
czech pockets i see
[ __ ] you see
you're in a dark room you have one
option that reads touch wall
okay um then i i guess uh uh of a power
of my free will i would like to touch
the wall please what a wonderful point
you've made about determinism out of
nowhere
and the nature of agency and gaming i
look eagerly forward to not reading this
thesis
yes you caress the wall it's indifferent
to you
there is now because this game is very
well designed one other option every
it's touch other wall
i feel like i've squirreled myself into
uh into a terrible fate but i shall
touch the other wall well now the first
wall is jealous
you may now touch yet another wall
apologize or
kick wall
a sudden overwhelming violent urge
has just overcome me um i'm gonna kick
the wall
yes what a fine journey perhaps the best
protagonist the dark room we'll ever
have
this is you oh i'm in a dark room
[Music]
yes you have kicked the wall perhaps in
an attempt to break the fourth one
perhaps just in an attempt to break your
toes let's see which one worked
oh congratulations the wall itself was
feeling very fragile and collapsed
and the ceiling wouldn't stand for this
bullying and fell down upon you
i have no choice but to inform you
[Applause]
folks if you would be so
good
wherever you are please the game breaker
literally tried to break the game and
then the game broke and now they're dead
folks a round of applause please for
ratters
thank you my friend thank you very much
i would just
one last thing to say i died doing what
i love
breaking things
it's glorious thank you
[Laughter]
perfect if anything a few people now are
sort of like
oh that's a bit reassuring she's dead
actually
that was one of the most frightening
things i've ever heard
thank you my love good on you thank you
no worries i'll see you later
watching see you later man can't figure
out how to hang up a discord call
bye that was radders everybody
another bloody joy another joy and you
know folks if you're oh what what wasn't
she good
you see the thing is folks you know when
you've done a discord call and asked how
did the call go
and you know how they they what they
really want you to say is how the tech
went
i liked her so much i gave her the big
smiley face tech was a bit broken
tech was a bit broken but she was great
now then
friends it's time for right now let's
have a look at how donations are going
because it looks to me as though they
are going absolutely bloody swimmingly
in fact folks if i could be so bold
good god in heaven
folks take a little moment please
strongest popped in 25
miss blackthorne 10 with the words
as a steadily growing more disabled
gamer i really appreciate all the work
you're doing now that's going out there
to gamespot that's going out there to
ablegamers
and if i don't get worse let's pay it
forward so more gamers can be born
that's very very beautiful
sami emma put in 35 saying take my money
and do good things with it
bapt friends has put in
1300 that's 1300
us dollars has been donated folks 1300
us dollars now do you reckon
do you reckon folks i think that's
incredible thanks dj yo bro to you as
well
but do you record friends we can get
that up to five grand
you reckon we can get that up to five
grand before the end of the stream i
absolutely reckon we can but isn't that
amazing isn't that amazing look at that
b.a.p.t popping in 1300 us
us dollar guns us dollar stars and
stripes there we go bloody brilliant
isn't it
bloody brilliant now what i reckon
friends you're all doing so wonderfully
and thank you all very much
why don't you and me that's you in the
chat doesn't matter where you are
or in the discord right you and me are
going to have another round of dark room
and then we're going to bring out
yogscastlo martia she's a twitch
ambassador
she does a lot of charity work a bloody
generous human being
it's going to be a joy good day to james
g'day to james as well hello
and if anyone in the chat just wants to
again talk about some of their favorite
games you let me know
you let me know just say hello and you
know i'll i'm not gonna lie i'll
probably rip apart your favorites
because
i have no other way of making friends
i'm an internet person you see
so gang here we go no absolute champions
all of you
ah general reminder yep no sorry i
misspoke before
misspoke before that's lamaria there
coming in twitch ambassador
and nothing else there we are sorry
about that yep there we are
yes i somehow remembered that
spontaneously and no one had to send me
an off-camera message
so then now let's get it going
[Laughter]
all right i'm not reading that one now
then
let's begin so are you ready
are you set okay that was some
good and classic good and classic
no behind the fourth what shut up
everyone i could see pricks they're
making fun of me in the discord
they're making fun of me in the discord
tamil
tamil you're now you're now going to be
on at 8. the stream's finishing by then
we're putting you on a date
bastards look at you go right then
here we are ready one two
three pieces of [ __ ] one two
three just cause you're right you awake
to find yourself
in a dark room i'm just gonna quietly
quietly move them i'm just moving it
i'm just quietly moving the discord
where i can't see it where the various
special guests are now yes
oh and radders put in 20 bucks rad is
putting 20 bucks with the phrase you
play you play you play you play because
games are for all
yes they are hence the name of the
charity play for
all so friends here we go here we go
pick your options by writing down the
colors go go go go go go pick your
options
and let's see what happens you are weak
to find yourself
in a dark room hashtag personal hashtag
pro streamer
now then what it be thank you writers
gaming
eyeglass86 putting in 50 and samantha
putting in 15.
thank you all very much now hello izzy
starsky who gave a wonderful round of
applause before for all the donors
now let's get going select select with
the colors
select with the colors your friends
select select select
come on why is this taking so long why
why am i so wrong am i so wrong to
expect that you would all for instance i
don't know for some reason be good at
video games
am i am i so incorrect
oh here we are it is twitch it
is gamespot one of the world's largest
gaming websites
hmm am i am i so wrong
am i so wrong to think that you'd be
good at gaming
now quickly now quickly i see that
there's a fair amount of people who are
very excited by the idea of going north
but it would appear friends oh dear oh
dear
oh dear you have selected again
find light switch all right
all right how will you find the light
switch
you're in a dark room you need the light
switch to see
do you see you're looking for x to skip
cutscene are you you're looking for x to
skip cutscene
oh we can make that happen
oh no everyone oh
no it looks as though raddersgaming
managed to break the game after all
oh i'm the blue screen of death
they call me windows i'm so unhappy that
the game's broken
oh john you're going to have to go and
get lomartia on
looks as though the chat played so badly
the game had no choice but to break oh
i can't believe it folks i can't believe
it that's amazing
i can't believe that you i mean look you
all i mean readers
you broke it apart ratters you broke it
apart and then you people i mean you
mean well
you mean well and you're donating you're
donating bloody beautifully which is
lovely but oy
oh you're bad at this game it seems as
though we're going to have to go and get
lovely lamaria lovely lamardia we're
going to have to bring on
lamaria there just a just a good old
twitch streamer
here we go then here we go folks i'm
going to make a call
let's go and a three and a two and a one
and a
half
let's see let's see what happens
hello hello how you doing
i'm right how are you i'm i'm doing fine
everything's everything's going okay
here nothing's broken
nothing's broken no no no
would you be so good la maria for the
people who require an introduction to
you and there won't be that many
who require an introduction but for the
people who just by some chance might
tell them a story who are you what do
you do
uh hello i am lamadia or hannah if
that's uh slightly easier for everyone
in chat
i'm a variety streamer twitter buster i
have been doing this stuff like 12 years
now
and uh yeah we're just carrying on
having some fun times playing some games
brilliant fantastic that's a tip i i
know you to be a
true bloody tremendous streamer and a
fine player of games and also a
god damn good advocate for charities um
okay and while all of this is deeply
admirable
what i've just noticed is something that
happened in the first five minutes of
the show
which i can now at least demonstrate to
people happen there's normally a poster
there
and of course when the room's dark
nobody knows let me just uh sort that
out now
here we are this is how intimate the
show's become hannah here go
get your get your bloody hands out of my
room get your hands out of my room
what oh no
uh i can try i'm doing it with like a
delay but
that's okay i always do it with the
delay if possible
nearly yes
oh yay there we go
yay well that pleases me that pleases me
amazingly
that was that was an absolute joy and
you know what i'm i don't think i don't
think i'm gonna fix the discord window i
like it
you can just yeah high five everyone
yeah i can high five everyone and also
if anyone was thinking of picking the
option that's in that corner oh no not
anymore
it's now invisible oh god
we've done very more no more check
pockets no more check pockets hang on
oh there you go oh hang on i've actually
got the ability to just
oh she left
oh thank you come back very good very
good yes there we go all right
oh the joy is a discord oh the joys of
discord
right then also um i just quietly i
shout out again
to the beautiful people of of gamespot
and um
and dejean luke their head of tech who
is just
really good at this stuff sent me a
whole bunch of stuff all of which works
all of which was explained really really
well and i just wrote back to him and
went
you know you know i'm gonna [ __ ] this up
right and he just sort of wrote back in
all caps
oh yes so we like him we like him a lot
he's good fun
now now lamaria come with me on a
journey
a journey to the dark room or or if you
want we can play a really fast game of
street fighter
do you want to play a really fast game
of street fighter sure
here we go why why didn't you play the
radars who was like kicking the wall
i feel like this would bend her thing
all right
i was scared of her she breaks
things she broke a cow while milking it
didn't you hear that part
i messed up news like that right
here we go ready
and hadouken
oh no there there but i don't even know
what i'm doing here oh no
no it's all right um no don't don't
worry um
to be honest with you uh that's that's
probably ended up exactly how i thought
it would
ah let me just uh
let me oh no just oh no here we go no
it's
okay it's just a charity show just
charity show it's always good to um
oh there they're right there why didn't
you block your fool
now then okay so lamaria
right let's play around with the dark
room hey mister darling just wrote stop
it stop it
mr damian j just wrote down fatality and
we have we've crossed the franchises
it has happened here we go it would have
been a better bloody crossover
than dc versus mortal kombat what a
phenomenal waste of everyone's time that
was right
you ready you're set yes i am
while we're here look at me hanging [ __ ]
on a game that came out 10 years ago who
am i
what culture right let's do it folks
all right right
[Music]
now then excellent lamaria
in your fine well-contained beautifully
rendered window
that's right yes keep your hands inside
the ride good stuff
now here we go
breaker of windows oh wait a minute
breaker of windows oh what a terrible
[ __ ] shame
oh no it looks like it's happened again
right as hell let's do this friend
one time two everyone then here we go
one two three all together
you awake to find yourself in a dark
room
your options are why sleep find light
switch or go
north go uh why why
because it's dark and a room and you're
awake in it
your options are sleep turn on light
switch or acknowledge you understand
sleep oh hang on they moved sleep
you've selected sleep fine fine worn out
worn out from
how good redder's turn was and the fact
that chat's still talking about it
not quite so sold on yours not quite so
sold on it
but oh no there's plenty of time you
sleep
and when sleep has ended you awake
to find yourself in a dark room
your options are why sleep fine light
switch or go north
pick one also hello to the dark piggy
hello dark piggy
hello mate i will have a round where the
chat plays in a second hey dude
now then ah the grumpiest and gothiest
of oinks
now then your options are wise sleep
find lights which will go north pick one
uh find light switch
having made the noise of a zombie
rising from the grave not because of a
virus but because of an
old-timey curse like in a black and
white film
you have selected find light switch how
will you find the light switch
you're in a dark room you need the light
switch to see
do you see your options are i see i
don't see
check pockets and the very popular czech
pockets
i see [ __ ] you see
you're in a dark room now i will just
say
you were in the chat for all of radda's
turn
and yet somehow we're now doing her turn
i did i did quickly go because i just
finished my stream so i did walk out at
one point and also thought i would be
spoiling it if i did too much
like watching of what she was doing and
i may have messed up there
no no no no no you're very lovely and we
all appreciate what you've done and
you're here for charity
and it's great and nevertheless you're
playing very badly and buck your game up
right then yeah touch one you caress the
walls are different do you touch on the
wall now the first wall is jealous
right then there are three options they
are kick wall
the red is special touch it another wall
or apologize ah
apologize you apologize
to the wall to the walls now
i'm just gonna i mean i may as well tell
you no one else will
they they don't they don't care
no now they're walls sort of just walls
mate
you know there's you know what i mean
jobs just sort of hold up the roof
that's that's it
there's one option it reads lean on wall
and weep
yeah i'll take it i'll take that
deciding that you've become emotionally
dependent
on the walls this is you
oh i'm in a dark room ah
i should have paid more or less
attention to this i can't figure out
which one is right
um
[Music]
sorry oh dear
you lean against the wall you cry
and to my mounting amazement
mark the time friends mark the time
one hour and 20 minutes into the charity
show
one hour 20 minutes in 18 minutes in
congratulations lamaria what
you have found the light switch
yes yes
oh writers can shove it up her ass now
yeah
rudders you have found the light switch
yes friend yes
by abandoning all hope by giving up
even searching you have found the light
switch
you lean against the wall and the tears
run
down your face and you know
as i say you have found the light switch
i feel the need to be oh a little more
honest
you haven't found the light switch oh no
tears have your tears run down the wall
they short circuit the light switch oh
no
[Applause]
hello
well played
oh no
i found the light switch i am happy with
it damn right
damn right be happy be full of pride
god damn it you did wonderfully you did
wonderfully and i'm happy
who would have guessed just being
completely useless
no no no no no if anything if anything i
almost feel
uh temporarily like being a um like
being a shout caster
like throwing out for post-match
analysis you know like okay you know and
what do you reckon her strategy was
there you know well almost that moment
of like you don't want to get
too engrossed in it you just want to
sort of want to go on instinct kind of
mixture of instinctive strategy and it
was really
amazing when she played tank i thought
yeah great you know so fabulous
so a lovely game of league of lamardia
was played beautifully
uh it's a real pity we were playing the
dark room um but that
that was a bloody joy friend uh have you
have you anything you want to tell the
people have you any as
the only finder of the light switch at
tonight's show
have you any words of wisdom for the
chat
who will be forced to play again the
second you're done
oh no i guess
you've got to work out how to not cry
i guess find the wall
second wall it looks like chat and
just don't don't cry don't cry
could be fine i don't know get a cup put
the tears in the cup
get a tissue oh god maybe there's a
tissue in your pocket
[Music]
possible spoilers i shouldn't be allowed
near this like choose your own adventure
books with my jam as a kid so no
i'm yeah no no radda's found the ceiling
i missed the ceiling oh my goodness
no no no raiders didn't find the ceiling
the ceiling found radders
um also just quietly folks obviously if
you do feel like crying just let it out
that's okay we're not all uh
not all toxically repressed
ah my love you're a bloody joy
your uh your twitch streams are a bloody
shining light they're
hugely enjoyable and you do a ton of
bloody charity work
uh folks if you would be so good
obviously go give lamar a follow
a remarkably excellent person uh yeah
thank you
mate all right have a good one everyone
have fun with the charity times i hope
you get out the darkroom
yay bye bye everyone
bye all right did we all just note that
at the end of that i tried to do the
bloody high five again i just went in
the wrong way
there we go wonderful wonderful
oh [ __ ] awake
to find yourself having turned off your
own camera
and we're back hello folks right
remember not to cry thanks lamaria
you looked the other way trying to look
at me i did
right then now friends
let's make something happen john can you
up your mic a touch uh
probably not actually in fact the answer
is no uh
so friends yeah sorry mate now then gang
lamaria well bloody played well bloody
played frendo well
bloody played indeed so gang it is time
once again
once again for all of the chat all of
the chat to play around of
the darkroom now you have all been again
donating bloody wonderfully remember why
we're
here we're not here for the fun of me
calling in friends of mine
and systematically alienating them
during my show which is what i'm
currently doing
we're not here so my friend lucy from
gamespot
can go why did we get him was he just
sort of the most available of my friends
yes um we're here because we are of
course raising money
for ablegamers and we are raising that
as part of
the play for all charity promotion and
you are all doing
wonderfully because when i look down
folks i see that octopus
octopus right here octopus g possibly
octopuses garden i like to be
under the sea with 250
250
yes friends yes bloody fantastic so look
at that
look at that folks we have breached five
grand
we've breached five grand this is
amazing i have a feeling
that so far i think we've raised
i could be wrong but i think of this
evening alone so far
i think we've raised about i want to say
about two thousand four hundred dollars
i want to say
i mean i i could be wrong and obviously
if anyone wants to uh wants to correct
me that's fine
of course if it's lower than that i mean
obviously don't tell me i'll be very sad
but um that's bloody phenomenal you
excellent people well let's keep it
going the show's going to go on
the show's going to go on until 8
o'clock which is 10 o'clock pacific
so we've got ourselves another 34
minutes let's see
how high we can go once again folks once
again
you're making the world more bloody
inclusive and that's wonderful
because let's put it this way we've all
had that moment where we've sat there
going
oh i can't i can't do this i'm not
invited i'm not able to get in
right and felt excluded that is the
experience sometimes of being disabled
one of the nicest things you can do is
turn around and go no i'm not going to
exclude that person
so bloody good on you and the way to do
that today is you pump some money in
there
well done good on you i like all of you
you're excellent people
i'm going to kill a few of you in a
minute but that's just an act now my
darlings let's make some stuff happen
we're going to play the darkroom if you
have just come in here's the video
that explains how it works um also
see if you can spot the part where uh
i've put this video on
because the streamer
might just need a piss see in a second
we are about to play a game a game that
is super easy
like your mom a game like the text-based
adventure games from the 1980s
and if you've ever played a text-based
adventure game
you know there are two words that
shouldn't have been in that sentence
and they are adventure and game
the rules are simple rule 1 find the
light switch
rule 2 find your family rule 3
escape the dark room
if you'll succeed you'll be reunited
with your loving attractive
unmutilated brethren and win this
beautiful flamboyant potato
[Music]
yes and so
we have returned one and all now then
friends let us play shall we
let us play some more i will count to
the number
three then and you know what that is
some of you that's two more people that
will ever touch you
i will count to the number three then i
will say the words you will wait to find
yourself in the dark room hello ray in
the city
giving us a raid thank you thank you ray
nice to see you
nice to see you we are currently raising
money playing the game the dark room
here for game spot so come in mate good
to see you
you're doing a wonderful thing here come
and play this game
here's how we do it four options are
about to appear on the screen
one will be blue if you want that one
you type in the color blue
it's always good to be blown or blue
which i believe is the present tense i'm
presently tense which means i'm good to
be blown
there we have sleep which is the color
yellow green
the color there for fine light switch
and red
the color of sweet succulent blood now
then
let's do this my friends hello drunken
ballsy wonderful
come on i just need a quiet lie down
right then
one two three everyone in the chat who
knows the words
you were weak to find yourself in a dark
room
now get amongst it friends get amongst
it we're on a live action video game
raising money for a disabled gamers
charity
and you write down the color of the
option that you want
pick one so far the chat has played very
badly
but has donated very nicely to the
charity
so get amongst it friends get amongst it
and then of course we're going to have
our friend tamil
tamil hussein is going to come and join
us folks and it's going to be wonderful
going to be wonderful in every hello
octopus gallery lovely place i like to
see all of our little squidgies
always a joy to see them gather together
in the octopus
gallery so yes friends everybody in
everyone go go go go go go go select
select what will it be what will it be
green
[Music]
now then if we get up to 5
500 raised we will have anime
catboy dance times now then you have
selected sleep
fine worn out
worn out worn out
from doing nothing you sleep
and when sleep has ended you awake to
find yourselves
in a dark room isn't that what you want
though
a little bit of ooh a little bit of woo
a little bit of notice me senpai
yes come on friends
a little bit of super genki neko kevin
chan
the people who just came in with ray in
the city good on you now come
in come and play this game donate some
money to the charity
stick around your beautiful people now
what will it be what will it be there
are again
700 screens in this game max skill you
need to write down the color
not just ask why well so it'll work
unless you were just asking why in
general
what why why do you want to see an anime
catboy dance because so help me god
you're on the internet
and what is the internet for except for
people who think they're cats
you have selected czech pockets
congratulations and anime
yes your pockets were made in the czech
room no they weren't
or they were made in the czech republic
sure but they're also just check pockets
now then what will it be with your sweet
check
pockets your sweet checkered little
pockets
you had your second vaccine shot today
did you wrestling god's streams
fantastic congratulations thank you
super win thank you laurie barry lovely
to see you
now then get amongst it get amongst it
[Music]
super win has backed yellow of course
folks wouldn't we all i mean if
superwind says it's true
that's not just a victory that's a super
victory that's the kind of victory that
can only be killed by doomsday and a
very ill-fated thing in 1994.
there you go one for the comic book
nerds you've selected put hands in
pockets
fine then you've put hands in pockets
how enjoyable what now
i mean this is literally your whole
adventure is it oh
here i am in a dark room time to get
casual
so then your hands are in your pockets
you're going to take your hands out of
your pockets you're going to take your
hands out of your pockets
or you're going to go north what are you
going to do
huh whatcha gonna do brothers
and sisters and everybody what are you
gonna do
oh now you're all very excited of course
you're excited got your hands in your
pockets most action you've seen in
months
you've selected take hans out of pockets
yes yes congratulations
congratulations yes yes
your beautiful friend hans your
beautiful
german friend hans there are bits of him
in your pockets
yes indeed yes it you little shits
hang on why why now
friends congratulations on finding a
screen you hadn't found before
it's a real shame that oh no
oh no on the blue screen
of death something's gone wrong with the
tech
oh no
[Music]
christ [ __ ]
plug in your bastard
oh no
christ almighty why now
[Laughter]
okay okay hi gang
so um
hi folks so hello hello everybody hi um
hey i hope we're all watching we're all
enjoying watching john [ __ ] up for
charity
if anyone just wants to donate some why
now
um folks so just um hang on just uh oh
christ right hang on let me just find an
appropriate cable
here we go uh so what's just happened
what's this happened friends
is um this cable has decided that it no
longer likes this computer
now that's um that's great i'm literally
having a moment where my controller's
just gone no that's enough
show that's enough show all right hang
on maybe you can connect to the
bluetooth you want to connect to the
bluetooth
connect to the bluetooth you like the
bluetooth connect to the bluetooth
when you have windows xp i know i know
connect to the bluetooth now
bluetooth devices why you do this now hi
hi folks hello to the people of gamespot
hello hello everyone hope you hope
you're all having a really
really good time i know i know i am i
know that um
my my big dream has always been to come
and do a charity show um
for a charity that i admire uh for a
news outlet that i respect
and uh to have
my [ __ ] game explode um
i blame raiders i blame raiders now then
hello then
oh you've got a meeting at three and you
want to get out of the darkroom well
i'll do what i can
rydo thanks cannon blaster ah now then
you're watching yes you're watching john
robertson live sponsored by dodgy wires
and bluetooth that doesn't want to
connect
netro there with the darkroom overlay's
still on i know
thank you mate that's not helpful hang
up
right let's try okay folks
i've got you didn't escape you didn't
escape just because the game died that's
not how it works
you don't escape when you knock the
chessboard off the [ __ ] table you
just ruined christmas
okay now it's all good hang on here we
go all right
okay
well friends congratulations
congratulations everyone you've unlocked
a new and exciting bonus round
a bonus round that i like to call
we'll be right back
[ __ ]
this is the song that you sing while you
fix things this is the song that you
sing while you fix
this is the song that you sing while you
fix things jesus christ we're
in the [ __ ] this is the song that you
sing while you fix things this is the
songs while you watch the thing
try to set up the bluetooth dongle
please do this
why is this happening this is the song
that you sing
when you are doing a charity stream and
you are currently
in the middle of a really horrible dream
sometimes it appears that maybe the
charity is just for me
cause i am let's face it yelp i'm the
one who needs the most help
jesus christ i'm having so oh my god
hi friends
[Laughter]
laughs
ah
well it was all it was all going so well
um [ __ ] hell okay
okay friends look okay
my loves my loves just give up on the
poster no
it's the only thing i can make work
right hang on
right ah okay
so just so everyone knows just
everyone knows friends just so everybody
knows okay
here's what has happened my computer
which is usually beautiful
has decided today's the day it doesn't
like the connection to the controller
but that's fine because i've got this
wireless dongle you see
got this wireless dongle and i've just
connected the wireless dongle to the
computer and it knows it's there
and this knows it's here and let's see
what happens
are you ready are you set this is yeah
you're having the
remixed mommy best bonus round ever yeah
i'm really enjoying a new and exciting
game of
sudden nervous breakdown right
folks okay okay in terms of service says
you can't show your dongle on twitch but
you can do it on youtube
right it knows it's there
it knows it's here
my dongle doesn't work mummy
folks i have a very strong
feeling that to get the controller
working again
we would need to restart the stream
so what i'm going to do right now folks
he has been here he oh that's fantastic
paul good on you mate
he has been waiting he was meant to come
on
at 6 15 he's been super cool in the chat
why don't we folks
why don't we bring on let's go and get
our friend
tamora on and let's say hi to turmoil
and let's see what we can do here we go
all right tamar are you there mate i'm
about to call you
here we go but hold up
hold up folks
it would appear that while everything's
gone to [ __ ]
people are excellent and a ton of money
has just been raised
so here we go tamar popped in 269 bucks
and said
please let me play
what a wonderful guy donating to his own
oh that's so good
anonymous pulled in five bucks binary
split with 20 bucks and then wrote
yellow
blue screen of death said 50. keith
hunter put in 10 saying look forward to
seeing kevin
blindyou says seems rude to enjoy the
show not put something in which could be
more five bucks
6502 puts in 20. tamor
is a bloody tip-top bloke i bloody
tip-top bloke
but folks i did say that if it hit five
thousand
five hundred quid that we would have
anime cat boy dance times
and so help me god i'm a man of my word
and we will do that we're okay
friends be ready
be ready folks there are some of you
there are some of you who will have no
idea what is going on here
there are some of you who will start to
understand it on an instinctive level
and will wish that it wasn't happening
but it is happening
you've raised that much money it's anime
catboy dance time
hey everyone
culture dancing
[Music]
next lovers
[Music]
truth and justice
[Music]
[Music]
you
there you go that happened
you can't deny that happened you can't
deny it happened
it all went on
now paul has just said i hope that you
are restarting the system while you're
dancing
i am not did
kevin's magic fix the controller
let's find out here we go that was super
genki neko kevin tran
coming out to join us he's my beautiful
cat mate flat knight flatmate he's a
beautiful boy sue [ __ ] [ __ ]
nope folks oh
hang on maybe but maybe there's a way
give a second
no no folks the only way to get this
going
the only way to get this going again
would be to stop streaming and i
do not think i do not think that i have
the emotional capacity or indeed even
the time to be fair
if i stop streaming it's going to take a
few minutes for them to get all of the
streams back out it seems like it'll be
a really uncomfortable thing for
everybody
but how about let's get out
onto the stage onto the screen he's your
friend
he's my friend he's an incredibly
patient man
let's say hi to tamor from gamespot
shall we folks
so i'm going to ring this lovely man and
let's have a word
let's do it oh
although i did just get a wonderful
message which was you need to be
friends with him to start a call so
that's good
in the meantime i don't know hey you
think you just pissed yourself that's
good
oh what's that clawed awkward please
stop ah claude you misspelt
awkward the way that i spell awkward
especially awkward [ __ ] whip
would be k l a u d e
capital f capital x there you go right
then
so oh we are friends what i know
i know when now we're friends let's have
a call
let's go get a hold
hello hello
seems like you just wake up and use a
personal computer today
well at the moment my personal computer
is using me
and it is using me using me as a bloody
target hello friend
how are you doing it's been an amazing
stream so far
it's been highs and there's been highs
and there's been more highs
as far as i'm concerned tech issues
included because
often you find that the problems create
fun
fun moments and opportunities to
come up with creative solutions
including a cat dance so
thank you very much uh i just i just
wanna one that's deeply encouraging of
you too
um how you sound remarkably like my
counselor that was very good
i know you know what i'm i'm go outside
hustle
of uh becoming a therapist on the side
so john
everything you've done today has been
for a greater good you might have
tripped and fell sometimes but you got
back up every single time
and we've raised a hell of a lot of
money you've done great work today
oh wonderful well why do we fall mr
wayne so we can get back up thank you
well folks as it turns out as it turns
out friends i didn't know if you knew
this right
i didn't know if you knew this but um
because the game's broken
what's lovely is a very patient human
being who also
at some point might i've got i've got a
story for you i think you'll like
but um we've got a very very supportive
human being who has been sitting
there for the last over an hour going
well i can't wait to play the game he's
actually gone and donated to the charity
saying can't wait to go to play the game
the game itself is broken but what's
wonderful
is that right now folks our friend tamil
our friend tamil
is giving out free therapy
free therapy ama tell me your problems
and i'll give you therapy in the chat
yeah john if you want to pick i will
just if you want to pick the questions
two things one we've got 10 minutes till
this stream ends
easy easy we are not licensed therapists
do not follow our advice
no i'll change your life in 10 minutes
but don't listen to anything i say
damn right also number three do not take
this as a serious opportunity
hey if you've got a problem that's a bit
silly pop that one in if you're gonna
trauma dump
now's probably not the time yeah if you
have genuine issues i
am not the right person for it and you
probably don't want to be putting it on
a
chat in the on the internet that's a
damn good point
also just quietly friend how long have
you been
well i mean you're a games journalist
you've been around the scene how long
have you been around pal
oh man i can't even tell you how long
it's been so i i
my first proper so i interned for
gamespot when i was
in universe no i think i was in universe
yeah i was in like my first year of
university or something like that so
it's been like
i've been in the industry for over like
nine years or something like that
my first actual paid working full time
was at cvg
um uh computer and video games magazine
yeah but i was like part of the team
that um had a website
uh worked on the website part of it and
i've been in the industry
on and off since i left for a year when
things started getting a bit weird
and when i worked on london underground
for a bit um
and then and i came back and now i'm uh
i'm a full-time gamer well it's nice to
see you back out of out of sweet
interest
were you working at um cvgv in about the
year 2013
just quietly i probably was honestly
time's a weird thing in my mind but i
probably was yeah all right
i'm gonna do this here we go why not
everything else has gone wrong
it's about time right so
when i agreed to do this stream i saw
the other day that you followed me and i
thought how tremendous
i like that bloke that's good my first
move to this country is the year 2013
i was very very eager very eager to get
work and i didn't quite understand
little uh little british eccentricities
like politeness
so what i did was i sent out a whole
bunch of emails that were
incredibly rude and incredibly along the
lines of g'day i'm here i'm [ __ ]
great give us something
and didn't hear back from any of those
people but you're one of them
what i didn't it really makes me happy
because i distinctly remember what i
said to you because i went
mate like it or not you'll hear of me
and that was my sign off
wait so i didn't reply or i did reply no
the next time i tried to reply i went
straight to spam
so when you showed up i was like well
now
oh no well that took eight years
[Laughter]
[Music]
it took years and when you get here the
[ __ ] game's broken
perfect well like this is this is the
one shot i gave you a shot i gave you
eight years to stew to really work
yourself up into your
to build to your perfect moment and we
got here and look what happened
well indeed did i did i make the wrong
decision
hey i'll tell you something pal this
isn't even my final form
i would love to see your final form if
you know what i'm saying
right well and that's how we just
discovered that i'm not using screen
share and tamil's on lag
so friends
now i see it now i see it it's coming up
on stream i see it now
that is that is terrifying and what
would that be on the gamespot ratings
metric
i i think it's if it's like uh in terms
of how good is that mask
it's probably about a seven but how
terrifying is it to
appear like suddenly being thrust
towards me that's a solid nine
yes that's a solid nine yeah for sure
just say
what a compliment is when you're
thrusting someone something towards
someone for them to go that's a solid
nine
thank you yeah actually that's what you
want it yeah that's right that's what
you want to
want to be in life like any time you
give me the gift of an extra inch and a
half but thank you very much i'm happy
to
see you today i'm feeling great i'm i'm
very glad to have anointed you a solid
nine with an extra inch and a half
what wonderful scented oil
now tell you what friend tell you what
we've probably got about um
probably got about five minutes but it's
up to you
how are you feeling because right now if
i look down i see that we have raised
five thousand six hundred dollars i
think i feel as though we need to say a
big thank you
to people who are popping that money in
let's see all right here we go 5
600 bucks again folks give yourselves a
round of applause that's amazing
eric d half of b popping in 60 bucks
rouge 6 10 bucks vault mog 10 bucks i'm
renewing the stage contract with that
poster it's a born comedian yes it is
and re nitro there with 15 we are
currently at
5 600 which i do believe means we've
raised
nine 2 dollars in this stream incredible
yeah fantastic
absolutely superb also a big shout out
there to paul
ehigi who says uninstall the xbox
drivers and reinstall it again
uh that's very good um i was with you
with several of those words
i'm incapable of doing any of those
things
now's not the time to uninstall stuff
yeah
but yeah that's that's that's that's
that's an incredible number
i mean like for folks that have are
seeing this for the first time like
darkroom is amazing
um so you should you should follow john
on twitter and also on twitch because
i mean you did a charity stream of your
own recently and
it raised an incredible amount of money
and that comes from a community that has
built around something
really special so if you you know tech
issues aside
um if you want to see more of this and
want to see how it real
really goes down and how cool it can be
make sure you follow
john and check out his streams but thank
you to everyone that has stuck around
thus far and and donated obviously we
are
raising money for ablegamers and as has
been discussed multiple times by various
various people including john and lucy
and others ablegamers is
an incredible that's a great way of
plugging yourself i'm seeing it on delay
now
but ablegamers is a charity that um
you know it's is i don't think it's an
understatement to say
it's like the future of video games in a
lot of ways uh video games
are striving to become more accessible
and ablegamers is at the forefront of
making sure that not only
are people with disabilities able to
play these games
and but the people that make these games
have an
expert kind of group a community of
uh a knowledge base to draw from when
they are not only
designing games but thinking about how
they can approach hardware you know
various
major companies that make the games that
you play and the hardware you play them
on
already work with ablegamers and they
have tracks for you know
educating as well as creating hardware
around that stuff so
when you are contributing to enable
gamers charity
um in the way that everyone has done
today so generously
you are literally making games better
for people in the future
games development easier for people in
the future and by opening gaming
up to more people you make you open the
door up to more creators too
and those creators are going to be the
next generation of
developers and designers there are kids
right now that are
you know might have disabilities that um
are you know
being enabled to play games through the
work that ablegamers does and
they playing a game because they can now
will spark
the idea of maybe i can create one of
these games
and then with any luck we'll they'll
move into a world where that kind of
development is enabled and there are
tools and companies that already can
welcome them and then before you know it
the next game of the year that you're
raving about could be created by someone
who
you know began life as a disabled gamer
so every dollar that you do donate
is is incredibly valuable and thank you
john for
you know putting on this amazing show
for us um it's been
amazing to watch and incredible to watch
thank you very much
and folks there we are it's not just
about whatever image you have in your
head where you think oh i'm going to go
help this i'm going to go help that
genuinely helping the future be a better
place for people
what a wonderful thing to do so folks
please donate right down there
to ablegamers tinyurl.com
um i thank you for your deep bloody
patience my friend
uh no worries no worries an
acquaintanceship eight years in the
making and just as broken as i thought
it would be
um and then that wasn't my fault
honestly honestly
honestly i'm going to be 100 honest with
you i thought i followed you ages ago
like literally ages ago and when i
noticed it it was deeply embarrassing
for me because i was like how
have i not noticed that i haven't
followed you all this time
because obviously you know lucy and i
like lucy and i talk about you
all the time like about the dark room
stuff so it is
i i i'm calling shenanigans on twitter
honestly
[Laughter]
well you're a beautiful man it was an
absolute bloody pleasure an absolute
bloody pleasure to be invited to do this
um if you are in if you are in the game
spot chat on twitch thank you very much
for your kind and beautiful attention if
you are in
the gamespot chat on youtube thank you
for your kind of beautiful attention if
you're hanging out on the discord
good on you what a fun time you must
have had playing a show you couldn't see
and if you're on my twitch thank you
very much your ongoing support means the
world to me thank you so much members of
my community for donating to this
and a final read of um
of donations that came in let's have a
let's have a final read there sneels
thank you very much
symbios 15 bucks sugoi apache flames
oh winged joe's helen c87 with 10 bucks
thank you all very much
you are all beautiful people and we will
see you again sometime
thank you and thank you very much good
on you enjoy play for all enjoy the
other streams
all right i'll see you again sometime